At the end of the day, we'd all prefer creating over debugging.
So how can we avoid debugging in the first place?
Here's some suggestions on what you can do.
First thing, get your requirements right.
Only if you know precisely what to do will you be able to know what not to do.
That is, only with precise requirements will you be able to tell failure from success.
A famous quote coming from Brian Kernighan:
"Without specification, there are no bugs--only surprises."
So you could think that if you have no specifications,
then you wouldn't have to do any debugging.
Unfortunately, surprises need to be debugged just as well,
except that debugging surprises is harder
because you don't know how they would not surprise you.
Increase precision and automation--next suggestion.
In the end, you do have this huge program
and you want to be able to find as many bugs as possible.
Of course you can have developers read it, review it, test it,
but in the end, the time of your developers will always be a precious resource.
In other words, you won't have the developers, you won't have the time,
and so you'll be pressed to ship anyway.
If you can automate these tasks, then resources will be much less of a problem
because you can have an arbitrary number of computers doing the checking for you.
This calls for techniques such a contracts, assertions, or other forms of specification
that can be validated automatically,
plus, of course, lots of automated testing that follows.
The next step is to reduce complexity.
The higher the structural complexity of a program,
the more ways there is for some part of a program to influence another
and the easier it is for infections to spread.
Plus the higher the complexity in a program, the more possible sources for infections there are,
and all of this makes debugging way harder.
Next step, set up assertions.
Every single assertion rules out large parts of the program or of the program state
as an infection cause.
And the more assertions you set up, the less state and statements do you have to examine
in order to figure out where the infection came from.
Next thing, test early and test often.
The earlier you test, the more precise your specification will be.
And the more you test, the more defects you will catch right away.
Plus, if you test frequently, you will be able to isolate the change that led to the test failing
by building on the past history of successful tests.
Next, review your code or have it reviewed by your colleagues.
Having your code being inspected by others has been shown again and again
to significantly increase productivity, quality, and project stability.
Next step, go and analyze the problem history of your project
in order to figure out which components have shown risk in the past and which ones haven't.
Obviously, components that had troubles in the past would always be the first ones to focus on
as it comes to improving quality.
Analyze their history, their common features, common causes,
and adjust the development process accordingly.
Last, learn from your mistakes.
Every bug you make is a bug too many.
Improve your development process such that bugs are caught as quickly as possible.
If a bug escapes into production, make sure it won't happen again.